welcome back more than a traditional
festival life is beautiful is a
three-day celebration that unifies the
concepts of art music goods comedy and
ideas jillian lopez is down in the
action during setup and she joins us
from ferguson's with an inside look hey
girl i love that hat
hey guys yes now i have the yellow hat
on i am loving all of these options that
we are seeing so life is beautiful is
all about music entertainment food but
of course supporting our las vegas
community so i'm here at market in the
alley which is located right across from
ferguson's downtown and i'm joined by
jen taller jen thank you so much for
being here and let's talk a little bit
about what actually market in the alley
is yeah absolutely so market's been
around since 2017. this is our fourth
mark uh market in life is beautiful and
it's all around supporting our local
creatives so we have over 50 different
local small businesses uh represented
during the festival so obviously i am
drawn to the hats here but you have a
lot of other stuff going on and people
are piling in as they will set up their
tables and their booths and showcase
some of their works of art so what are
some types of things that we can find
here in the alley absolutely you have
anything from art from
hat sets on your head right now
to stickers cups
really just kind of anything and
everything you can think of jewelry
accessories home goods really great
quality products that our local
creatives make and i think life is
beautiful has really taken our community
to the next level when it comes to
supporting our locals how important is
it to support the local artists and
businesses and just kind of all come
together during this really exciting and
fun weekend yeah absolutely i think more
importantly just after the year and a
half that we've all gone through it's
really important to put your dollars
into your local economy so having us in
the festival is huge because it gives a
great opportunity for these makers to
also reach outside of um our local
demographic and if people want to stop
by when are you open when can they come
see you friday saturday sunday 10 uh two
outdoors and then until 10 p.m so plenty
of time to shop and i'm just looking at
all these cute little things on the
table here there's cowboy boot earrings
sunglasses i mean everything you name it
look at this welcome to fabulous las
vegas nevada mug i think i need it and
jen you might just have to turn around
because i might just walk away with this
hat so you never saw it here
well thank you so much be sure to come
stop by market in the alley i see people
unloading their cars right now getting
ready it's going to be a lot of fun i'll
send it back to you guys thank you
jillian we'll check back with you during
the 4pm new newscast and i'm expecting
another hat too yeah right different
color